c'est toujours leur de babar issa avec
bravo loto le jeu 100% gratuit qui peut
changer ta vie
téléchargez l'appli jeter gris et tente
de remporter jusqu'à un million d'euros
sans rien faire bravo l'auto facile
d'être riche
on y va donc je dois boire pour le cab
au parc ou pas cap dans le nombril de
jean michel
à quel âge déjà son rythme il ya déjà du
liquide menacer la radio ckoi mais parce
qu'il sait nettoyer le nombril lectrices
dégueulasse baden c'est moi qui ai
commencé j'ai mis un peu d'huile de foie
de morue pour commencer maxi de l'huile
c'est l'huile de foie de morue que tu
fais plus beaucoup d'ados on voit que tu
as du succès la tellette a plus besoin
les gars c'est mou nous amène on n'a pas
besoin machado
[Musique]
alors c'est bien ça quand on commence
cherokee
[Musique]